vamos a hacer un repaso sobre la
actualidad Mundial de la Salud y nos
acompaña ya en el estudio más Romero
salah buenos días Rosa mar empezamos con
los resultados de un potencial
medicamento contra el alzheimer Que
supongo que une tanto esperanzas como
incertidumbres no por supuesto aquí
siempre intentamos ser prudentes ante
anunciar no a bombo y platillo que un
nuevo medicamento puede ser la solución
a esta enfermedad que afecta a millones
de personas en este caso es un
medicamento desarrollado por la
farmacéutica el lilíque tiene resultados
prometedores pero que tenemos que tener
prudencia empecemos porque son
resultados aunque son con una muestra
muy amplia más de 1.200 casi 1200
pacientes que participaron en este
estudio de fase 3 todavía no están
publicados en una revista científica
Entonces no están revisados por pares se
evaluó el deterioro cognitivo de los
pacientes primero en las personas que
tomaron placebo y después de un año de
tomar ese placebo un 29% de los
pacientes no tenían no habían tenido
ningún de cognitivo en el caso de los
pacientes que sí tomaron el medicamento
fueron un
47%, los que no tuvieron un deterioro
cognitivo después de un año Por lo tanto
parece que arrojó esos resultados
positivos además otro dato que da la
farmacéutica es que ese se ralentizó ese
deterioro en un 35% en los pacientes que
tomaron el medicamento esto no viene sin
algunos contras por supuesto los
pacientes que tomaron el fármaco
mostraron más casos de inflamación
cerebral y de micro hemorragias que
hemos visto en otros medicamentos que
funcionan de forma parecida un 1,6% de
los pacientes entre estos que tomaron el
medicamento tuvieron incidentes graves
en este sentido y hubo tres que
desafortunadamente fallecieron a raíz de
estos incidentes mar ya te conocemos y
sabemos que la prudencia siempre por
delante en esta sección le pregunto
exactamente cómo funciona este
medicamento un poco paradamies que se
dice para que lo podamos entender todas
Sí muy fácilmente tiene
Diana muy particular que se llama
amiloide que es una proteína que se
genera una placa se va acumulando en el
cerebro y evita que se puedan transmitir
bien las neuronas que hay una buena
conexión neuronal y esta placa se
considera además un marcador definitorio
del Alzheimer el medicamento Busca
limpiar esta placa y es la misma teoría
el mismo funcionamiento que tienen
varios medicamentos dos particularmente
que ya se han aprobado en Estados Unidos
escuchemos precisamente una voz experta
en esta materia que nos lo explica
afectan distintos puntos en la cascada
de amiloide pero sin embargo producen el
mismo resultado de reducir la cantidad
de placa de amiloide Y eso se traduce en
una ralentización de la progresión de la
enfermedad es importante no para la
enfermedad no hace que la gente mejore
Pero puede reducir la velocidad a la que
empeoran
es muy importante que recordemos que
esta teoría de atacar el amiloide para
Pues ralentizar el alzheimer no tiene
consenso de toda la comunidad científica
años de fracasos en este sentido
hicieron dudar a muchos y también hay
gente que dice que estos medicamentos
que tienen este funcionamiento al final
su mejora clínica de los pacientes es
tan poco es poco significativa como para
extraer conclusiones sin embargo Es
verdad que estos últimos resultados sí
parecen hacernos creer que se afianza
cada vez más con más solidez de esta
perspectiva Mari antes de que
eventualmente se llegue a probar algún
día este medicamento hoy en día
qué fármacos hay para tratar el
alzheimer pues además de todas las
terapias Así que lo que hacen es un
manejo de síntomas hay dos medicamentos
aprobados en Estados Unidos por la fda
comercializados ahí también que como
decíamos también tienen esta misma
funcionamiento de atacar el amiloide
esta proteína que se acumula en el
cerebro y para retrasar el deterioro
cognitivo del Alzheimer el primero que
se aprobó se llama aducanumap se
comercializó bajo el nombre de adujem Y
fue desarrollado por la farmacé se
aprobó en junio de 2021 el segundo es el
decanemap lo hemos tratado en esta misma
sección con anterioridad se comercializó
como lecandi y se desarrolló por biogend
y también la farmacéutica e Isai y se
aprobó muy recientemente en enero de
este mismo año el último el de Lily que
estamos hablando y que conocimos ayer
los resultados se llama Don anemap
todavía no está comercializado se suma a
esta lista Pero además como vemos todos
tienen precios bastante prohibitivos
alrededor de 25.000 28.000 dólares
anuales esos son más de 2000 dólares
mensuales para poder acceder a este
tratamiento por eso no antes de
proclamar esta Esperanza como decíamos
toca también tener en cuenta como de
costosos son estos medicamentos y
también una polémica que hubo con el
primer medicamento que se aprobó en la
ducanumap porque hubo mucha controversia
se dijo que se aprobó con demasiada
velocidad sin tener Claridad sobre sus
efectos positivos y hubo muchos médicos
por ejemplo que se negaron a recetarlo a
sus pacientes porque las mejoras que
podían Mostrar no estaban claras por el
precio que costaba al final ese ese
medicamento una muestra al final de que
la prisa por tener un fármaco contra el
alzheimer que sin duda es muy urgente
puede llegar a jugar también pues malas
pasadas y que este marketing de Las
farmacéuticas necesita estar apoyado con
datos científicos que parece por suerte
Que si vamos recabando ya en los últimos
meses mar Muchísimas gracias por este
repaso no sobre este panorama en la
lucha contra el haceme Muchísimas
gracias Gracias Rosa